[Música]
boa tarde
tudo bem com vocês
tem eventos na vida da gente que provoca
um conexão como a gente se jogar de
cabeça naquilo que a gente faz a gente
ouvir o outro com uma vontade genuína de
entender a gente se colocar no lugar do
outro e tem eventos que provocam a
desconexão como o medo o julgamento
o egoísmo e quando a gente fica sem um
efeito também o design thinking ele é
uma abordagem que vem sendo usada por
muita gente para resolver problemas
complexos de uma maneira inovadora e eu
percebi que ele carrega dentro dele um
espaço onde essas duas forças de conexão
e desconexão sempre sempre sempre se
encontram
eu chamo esse espaço de gravidade zero
o acesso a ele pode ser feito não por
fora mas por dentro está condicionado a
história de vida de cada um
então dessa maneira esse acesso ele pode
ser feito de inúmeras formas mas tem um
elemento fundamental que facilita esse
nosso acesso a esse espaço de gravidade
zero e faz com que a gente pensa de uma
maneira inovadora e que a gente aja de
uma maneira inovadora
esse elemento é o desapego
[Música]
quem foi que disse foi eu acho nada
o bandido abandonou o futebol em angola
e japão
segue se o governo tcheco
a rádio paiquerê am
bonito de itatí initio de itatí você
precisa se soltar
eu assisti esse filme num período
bastante difícil da minha vida eu tinha
sido desligado de uma empresa depois de
17 anos de carreira eu tinha terminado
um casamento de sete anos e me separar
de alguém que amava muito e estava com
42 anos de idade e ouvir as pessoas
dizerem que a vida começa aos 40
para mim parecia que estava acabando
quando o filme acabou m de mulher de
chorar no cinema sem saber porque
chorava compulsivamente as pessoas
embora e acabando de chorar e só um
tempo depois eu fui perceber que eu
estava pegado algumas idéias obstinados
que eu tinha respeito de mim mesmo que
estava me levando para muito muito longe
de onde eu precisava e queria estar
naquele momento como esse braço mecânico
que prende astronauta e vai empurrando
ela pra dentro da escuridão
por coincidência ou não eu acho que não
existem coincidências na vida foi mais
ou menos nessa época que eu conheci
comecei a estudar o design thinking e de
lá pra cá eu venho facilitando o
trabalho de alguns profissionais que
estão usando abordagem pra inovar na sua
maneira de pensar e de agir e resolver
problemas
eu não sei se vocês viram esse filme mas
eu vou narrar mais algumas cenas para
fazer uma analogia com o que eu vejo que
vem acontecendo com as pessoas quando
elas usam o design thinking
alguns minutos depois dessa cena quando
eles são atingidos por alguns fragmentos
de uma nave a doutora stone que é
interpretada pela sandra bullock alpb
consegue entrar de volta na estação só
que o companheiro dela um caos que ele
fica do lado de fora
ela fica desesperada e ela tenta acionar
os comandos praí resgatá lo naquele
momento mas os dois sabem que essa nave
só tem combustível suficiente para levar
doutores tom até uma outra estação que
está abandonado ali perto o caos que
entra com um contato com ela pelo rádio
e fala assim você vai ter que embora
não tem outra solução então nós dois
vamos morrer você precisa aprender a
abrir mão
ela não tem escolha
do lado de fora começa acionar os
comandos da nave e parte em direção a
essa outra estação que está abandonada
ali perto perto no espaço é um conceito
meio maluco né
mas por ali onde ela conseguiria chegar
mas ela parte sozinho amedrontado rumo
ao desconhecido ela não sabe o que ela
vai encontrar lá na verdade quando ela
chega nessa estação abandonada ela entra
na estação e ela tem uma surpresa ter
rodado a terra aterradora terrível
ela vê que ali também não têm
combustível para voltar para a terra
então ela se vê dividida entre a fundar
na própria morte ou fazer uma descoberta
que carregue ela pra longe dali em
direção à terra com vida
esse filme gravidade do afonso parou de
não sei se vocês já assistiram já dei os
espólios que precisava não vou contar o
que acontece no final do filme
mas essa cena servem para continuar a
minha narrativa e fazer essa analogia
como falei anteriormente o design
thinking é uma abordagem usada para a
solução de problemas complexos centrado
nas pessoas
e ele tem esse espaço dentro dele onde
as pessoas fazem uma viagem parecida com
essa que os astronautas fazem no filme
só que com o resultado mais animador
o design quem começa sempre com o
entendimento de um problema um desafio
que a gente quer resolver
então por exemplo se eu chegasse aqui
pra você falasse como é que a gente pode
tentar maximizar o compartilhamento de
conhecimento nessa sala
como é que vocês entenderam essa
pergunta como é que vocês vêem esse
desafio
naturalmente vocês começaram a sessão um
repertório mais familiar de vocês
as idéias que a gente conhece o que está
na superfície mas o risco é que a gente
se apega de mais essa idéia
o que está certo é que funciona o que a
gente já sabe
e aí vai a gente fica aprisionado no
mesmo lugar e aí a gente não consegue
enxergar além disso a escritora francesa
na slim uma vez afirmou que a gente não
vê o mundo como ele é mas como nós somos
o que eu percebi acontecer com as
pessoas que usam o design thinking é que
na ânsia de tentar descobrir uma nova
maneira de enxergar as coisas elas
esquecem de se perguntar como é que ela
se desapega da antiga
a partir daí dessa etapa de entendimento
do problema
a gente convida as pessoas a fazerem um
mergulho no universo de quem está
envolvido naquele contexto
naturalmente quando a gente tem um
desafio um problema a gente se pergunta
como é que eu resolveria isso mas
dificilmente a gente se pergunta o que o
outro precisa
como é que ele vê esse problema e eu
queria propor um exercício para vocês
stop rodrigo acende a luz por favor da
platéia
eu queria que vocês localizar-se não
precisa levantar mais localizem alguém
perto de vocês que vocês não conhecem um
completo desconhecido troquem olhar
vejam aí onde a questão se acharam tem
que ser desconhecido localizar alguém
não encontrou todo mundo achou pelo
menos uma dupla ali levanta a mão vamos
ver se alguém acha ela que não conhece
alguém pode fazer corre rapidinho ali
junta aqui vêm cá levantar rapidinho
pode ver só ficar perto um do outro
vai ser bastante simples tá vocês vão
virar de frente pra esse desconhecido
você se conhece não valem a bom tá de
olho fica indiferente para esse
desconhecido e vocês vão olhar no olho
dessa pessoa durante os próximos 30
segundos
321 valendo parece pouco tempo mas não é
olha olha no olho passou só cinco
segundos sustenta continua olhando não é
jogo dá risada pode rir mas continua
olhando o quê 20 e só falta 10 sustenta
mais um pouquinho 5 4 3 2 1 beleza valeu
obrigado
fala pra mim qual a sensação não é muito
legal não né
é mais desafiador mas um que sentiu
engraçado da uma estranheza né porque
que isso acontece cara quando a gente
olha no olho do outro a gente está
acessando mais profundo da alma não tem
barreira nenhuma
você tá enxergando quem é esse ser na
sua frente
essa conexão com o outro um desconhecido
ela é perturbadora porque a gente sai de
um lugar seguro familiar o nosso terreno
aqui quentinho e eu vou lá pra onde eu
não sei o que é eu não sei isso eu não
sei o que tá rolando ali me perturba
depois dessa etapa que a gente faz um
mergulho no entendimento do problema
junto aos outros pra gente enxergar como
é que esse problema a gente chega
finalmente numa reinterpretação desse
desafio que a gente tinha lá no início
ou seja como é que eu a partir do
desapego que eu faço das idéias que eu
tenho através o outro e juntos a gente
pode fazer uma nova descoberta
a gente pode encontrar novos caminhos
pra onde que a gente vai a partir daí
mais ou menos esse é o processo do
design thinking o que eu venho notando
venho notando que nesse nessa prática do
desapego que eu
faço das minhas idéias pré-concebidas
dos meus dos meus preconceitos
nessa jornada em direção ao desconhecido
e nessa tentativa de encontrar uma nova
descoberta
eu abro um espaço de gravidade zero onde
essas forças de conexão e desconexão
ficam se degladiando tempo inteiro ea
emerge uma terceira que é a desconexão
que essa desconexão
é como se fosse um estado de atenção
flutuante onde você consegue sair de
você mesmo e não se apegar nada ninguém
nem coisa boa nem coisa ruim você só
observa as forças que estão lá lutando
agindo para fazer essa travessia precisa
de uma boa dose de coragem assim como os
astronautas precisaram nesse filme anais
nin a mesma escritora que eu já aceitei
agora a pouco ela falava também que a
vida se contrai e se expande
proporcionalmente à coragem dos
indivíduos coragem que a gente precisa
ter pra fazer essa travessia era um
desconhecido e encontrar uma maneira de
criar um mundo novo
diferente do que a gente conhece
desapegados livres suspensos como se a
gente flutuasse a gravidade zero
[Aplausos]